factorizar el máximo factor común de 4x
a la cuarta y más 8 x al cubo y ok
entonces tenemos que hacer dos cosas uno
determinar el máximo como un factor o
máximo factor común de ambos mono mios y
luego tenemos que factorizar lo de este
binomio ok recuerda que esto de máximo a
mí me gusta ponerlo entre comillas
porque no es máximo en un sentido
numérico no conocemos quién es xy y
entonces pues no sabemos si es negativo
o si x es menor que 1 así que no
podremos ordenarlo sino más bien cuando
hablamos de máximo factor común hablamos
de el factor que tiene pues la mayor
cantidad de factores de ambos mono mios
y para determinar esto pues lo primero
que tenemos que hacer es factorizar cada
uno de estos déjame copiar el 4x a la
cuarta y aquí 4x a la cuarta y entonces
para factorizar lo primero factor izamos
este 4 en primos que nos quedaría 2 x 2
y luego tenemos que factorizar este x a
la cuarta o bien bueno desarrollarlo
ponerlo con todas las x es x x x x x x x
esto de aquí es quizá la cuarta y luego
multiplicamos por esta y porque ésta
llegue a la 1 entonces ahí está porque
vamos a hacer lo mismo con el segundo
mono mió entonces el segundo es 8 x al
cubo jr
y eso de ahí cuando lo factor izamos
bueno cuando factor izamos el 8 nos
queda 2 por 2 por 2 cuando factor izamos
o cuando desarrollamos está x al cubo
nos queda x por x por equis y finalmente
la aie pues otra vez nos queda por ye
verdad ahora ya que tenemos la
factorización de ambos lo que tenemos
que hacer es ver cuáles son los factores
o cuál es la mayor cantidad de factores
que podemos tomar que estén en ambos
déjame marcarlos con este color blanco
empezando con los doses aquí tenemos 22
de ellos y aquí arriba también tenemos
perdón aquí abajo también tenemos 2
entonces la máxima cantidad de dos que
vamos a poder tener son dos entonces
déjame ponerle por aquí dos por dos muy
bien ahora vamos con las x es aquí
tenemos 13 x es y aquí también tenemos 3
arriba y 4 pero abajo no entonces máximo
podemos tomar tres de estas tres y estas
tres digamos
entonces las copiamos aquí abajo x x x x
x x y finalmente con las 10
bueno pues ambas expresiones tienen ya
tienen y entonces hay que multiplicar
por y por una sola y porque una ya
aparece en ambas muy bien déjame déjame
desarrollar estoy acá estoy aquí es
igual a bueno simplificarlo igualados
por dos es 4 x x x x x s x kubica y
finalmente tenemos muy bien entonces ya
tenemos el máximo factor común y lo que
queremos es lo que queremos hacer es
factorizar lo de esta expresión de cada
uno de los términos entonces tenemos
como que de distribuirlo verdad ponerlo
aquí afuera 4 x al cubo porque y aquí
adentro tenemos que poner una
multiplicación para que nos quede lo
mismo que aquí arriba como ya hacemos
para pensar en esto a pues de este
primer término lo voy a escribir como 4x
a la cuarta y quizá la cuarta y el de
arriba también lo voy a poner 8 x algo
pero ahora déjame dividir cada uno de
estos entre
x al cubo entre 4 x al cubo y observa de
acá acá no cambiamos en nada de hecho
puedes distribuir este 4x al cubo ye
para ver que regresamos a la expresión
original
entonces puedes distribuirlo ver que
regresamos a este entonces ambas son
iguales pero ahora si podemos
simplificar lo de adentro que nos
quedaría afuera sería 4x al cubo ye y
adentro nos quedaría x a ver aquí
tenemos que simplificar 4 entre 4 es 1
entonces no lo pongo luego x a la cuarta
entre quizá al cubo pues restamos los
exponentes verdad 4 - 3 es una búsqueda
x y llegue entre y es uno tampoco lo
pongo y a eso tengo que sumar
tengo que sumar 8 x al cubo entre 4 x al
cubo y el 8 entre el 4 es un 2 si pongo
el 2 x al cubo se cancela con x al cubo
y que también se cancela con ye muy bien
entonces aquí tenemos la factorización
que estábamos buscando hay otra forma de
pensarlo hay otra forma de pensarlo
aprovechando que ya tenemos estas
factorización es osea si vamos a sacar
el factor 4x al cubo y de ambas entonces
lo que estamos haciendo es sacar esta
parte digamos esta parte y esta parte de
modo que lo que nos sobraría en el
primer término sería esta x esta x y
abajo pasa algo similar estamos quitando
esta parte quitando esta parte y
quitando esta parte que es el factor
común y lo que sobra es este 2 es este 2
y por lo tanto adentro quedaría x + 2
justo como sucedió aquí va entonces esa
es una forma de pensarlo como lo que
sobra y bueno finalmente no es necesario
hacer todo esto ahorita lo hice con
mucha calma para ver de dónde salen cada
uno de los pasos pero en realidad ya que
agarramos un poco de práctica podríamos
decir lo siguiente voy a volver a copiar
la expresión 4x está la cuarta y más 8 x
al cubo yen
entonces con un poco de práctica
podríamos decir bueno cuál es el máximo
número que divide a 4 y 8 a 4
entonces ponemos el 4 la máxima potencia
que divide a x a la cuarta y x al cubo a
pues x al cubo y además tenemos estoy
aquí y aquí entonces y ya nada más como
que uno lo piensa y dice ok cuánto me
sobra pues este 4 este 4 ya lo saqué y
aquí teníamos x a la cuarta y ya sea que
x al cubo entonces ahí queda una equis y
está ya la saqué no queda nada más y en
el segundo sumando tenemos que ya
sacamos 4 pero teníamos un 8 entonces
quedan 2 y el x al cubo y el jet también
ya lo sacamos
entonces ya agarrando un poco de
práctica vas a poder factorizar el
máximo factor factor común de un binomio
de esta manera bueno nos vemos hasta la
próxima